President Trump will leave the White
House shortly to begin several days of
high-stakes diplomacy his first stop is
the g7 summit in Quebec where he expects
tough talks with the six US allies
Canada France Britain Germany Italy and
Japan relations are tense to put it
mildly after the president put new
tariffs on imported steel and aluminum
from the European Union Canada and
Mexico those nations are now threatening
new tariffs on their own US products the
president already tweeted this morning
looking for just straightening out
unfair trade deals with the g7 countries
if it doesn't happen we come out even
better which is Jiang is in Quebec City
Canada ahead of the summit that starts
later today we should good morning
good morning to you president Trump's
america-first mantra has led to policy
decisions that have angered US allies g7
finance ministers already met ahead of
this summit and they described the group
as g6 plus one with the u.s. in the rare
role of an outlier then we're going up
to the g7 on the eve of the g7 summit
president Trump said little about his
goals but had messages for two of the
leaders he plans to meet with Trump
tweeted Canadian Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau quote is being so indignant and
slammed both Trudeau and French
president Emmanuel macron for their
tariffs on the u.s. kitchen keeper one
kiss from Plan C McCrone and Trudeau
said they would not back down to mr.
Trump who says his administration's
recently imposed tariffs will help keep
the u.s. safe
it is laughable Prime Minister Trudeau
said to say that Canada France represent
a threat to America's national security
the g7 summit typically concludes with
all seven leaders signing a joint
communique there's a chance that won't
happen President McCrone tweeted the
other six leaders wouldn't mind signing
one without the u.s. at the White House
Thursday president Trump hosted japan's
Prime Minister Shinzo Abe a who will
also attend the g7 but that other summit
coming up in Singapore stole the
spotlight I think
preparing for the summit for a long time
as has the other side is he going to be
too distracted by his trip to Singapore
president is at ease with all these
tough issues he's proven himself to be a
leader on the world stage but president
Trump is leaving the g7 early he will
travel directly to Singapore tomorrow
morning and the US has also broken with
the other countries breaking out of the
Iran nuclear deal and clashing with them
over how to address climate change and
he will by the way be missing
discussions about that
Alex Mita thanks